the State Department is investigating
the mysterious disappearance of a blind
Michigan woman who was reported missing
in Peru Karla Val PES was last seen a
week ago while traveling near the
historic city of Machu Picchu in the
Andes Mountains
David beg know is here with how her
family and friends are desperately
trying to retrace her steps David good
morning IANA good morning Karla travels
a lot so her family's really worried she
was in Peru her family says for a
wedding and plan to return to Detroit
last Saturday but they say she missed
her flight home and has not been heard
from in more than a week Carlos Lopez
has spent the past two days
frantically looking for his 35 year old
daughter Karla he flew to Peru Tuesday
morning and does not plan to return to
the US without her God Karla dad is here
he says call us tell us where you are
Valdez is family says she was planning
to stay in Peru for more than a week
attending a wedding in Lima celebrating
her birthday and hiking to Machu Picchu
in the Andes Mountains she met some
people there that helped her hike up
Valdez's brother Carlos says she arrived
in Machu Picchu alone but left with a
tour group that invited her to spend the
night in a nearby hostel in Cusco early
the next morning he believes she
continued her journey by herself
possibly boarding a bus to two nearby
cities I've had the opportunity to
travel to many different parts of the
world
Valdez started traveling the world after
she lost her eyesight when she was 7
years old she's been to Yemen she's been
to the desert and Egypt you know this
isn't her first trip
Alicia's steal a friend of a PEZ joined
her for the start of the trip in Peru
yes yes yes Kim said it was nothing it
has been 7 days that we have not heard
from her she says she could be hungry it
could be anything please help us Carlos
says the last time his sister was seen
on security footage was at the hostel he
says it shows her getting into the taxi
which he believes she took to the bus
station in Cusco look John her family
stresses to us it is completely out of
character for her to be missing flights
or for that matter not communicating
with them
David thank you I hope they get some
good news